et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Manuel Bompard coordinateur de la France
insoumise députée des Bouches-du-Rhône
bonjour bonjour alors nous sommes
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale qui représentée
aujourd'hui par Fabrice wesser Redon
bonjour rédacteur en chef au groupe Ebra
des journaux de l'Est de la France
manuel bon parent on va commencer par
évoquer l'élection législative partielle
en arrière avec et bien cette échec pour
la nupes la victoire de la candidate
dissidente socialiste Martin Froget
contre la députée sortante insoumise
Bénédicte taurine qui était soutenu par
la nups comment vous expliquer cette
défaite
c'est une défaite effectivement alors
d'abord c'était pas une candidate
dissidente socialiste puisque elle
n'avait été exclue du Parti socialiste
elle n'en était pas membre
bénédictorine est arrivé en tête du
premier tour de manière assez large
dimanche dernier et là manifestement ce
sont regroupés autour de cette
candidature dissidente les voies des
macronistes les voix de la droite les
voix de l'extrême droite d'ailleurs
j'observe que ceux qui saluent
aujourd'hui l'élection de Madame projet
sont vont même de Monsieur dussobe
jusqu'à monsieur Odoul qui est
porte-parole du rassemblement national
donc voilà je pense qu'il y a une forme
de coalition de circonstances pour
essayer de battre la candidate de la
nups et je le regrette c'est la faute
aux divisions du Parti socialiste car
Martin Froget est quand même soutenu par
des cadres du PS animalgo Carole Delga
le numéro 2 du PS Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol ah bah clairement on peut pas
dire que l'ensemble du Parti socialiste
a été en soutien de la candidature de
Bénédict taurine ça c'est une évidence
moi je rappelle que avant à gauche il y
avait une sorte de la tradition qui
était que quand il y avait deux
candidats de gauche au second tour on
évitait de laisser la liberté aux
électeurs de droite et d'extrême droite
d'arbitrer entre les deux candidats de
gauche au second tour et je regrette que
ça n'est pas été le cas cette fois-ci et
effectivement je pense que le Parti
socialiste doit être dire clairement
quel est son orientation soit le parti
socialiste et en faveur de la nupes que
je souhaite puisque je suis attaché à
cette à cette alliance soit le parti
socialiste ne le souhaite pas mais vous
pouvez pas avoir dans la même
organisation politique deux orientations
comme ça qui se confrontent ça décharge
le premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste a été particulièrement réglo
avec vous je ne conteste pas bien
évidemment Olivier fare a tenu la parole
des socialistes puisque la parole de ces
socialistes était qu'il y a un accord de
la nups et que c'est cet accord de
laupes qui s'appliquait il a tenu la
parole mais il tient pas les socialistes
c'est ce que manifestement mais c'est je
veux pas lui en faire le reproche mais
ce que je veux dire est-ce qu'il faut
que tout le monde comprenne c'est que je
peux comprendre qu'il y a des
spécialistes qui s'interroge sur
l'accord de la nups mais je voudrais
quand même rappeler que l'année dernière
il y aurait pas eu le groupe socialiste
à l'Assemblée nationale s'il n'y avait
pas eu l'accord de la nupes et que quand
on fait un accord comme ça il y a des
circonscriptions ou c'est les
socialistes qui sont les candidats de la
nups et puis il y a des circonscriptions
ou c'est pas les socialistes qui sont
les candidats de la nups et si les
endroits où c'est pas les socialistes
qui sont les candidats de la nups
finalement il y a d'autres socialistes
qui se présentent quand même et ben
parce qu'il y a plus d'accords de la
nups du tout donc il me semble que
Olivier fort a tenu de ce point de vue
là le cadre de la nupesse et qu'il avait
raison de le faire en tout cas Martin
Froget veut siéger dans ce groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée qui fait partie
de l'intergroupe nupes elle serait
légitime assiégée dans ce groupe ah bah
je crois d'abord que les socialistes
sont déjà répondu à cette question enfin
si j'ai bien lu le communiqué qui a été
publié hier par la direction du Parti
socialiste ils disent que
malheureusement on a perdu un député de
la nups donc j'entends par là que la
députée qui vient d'être élue ne sera
pas me d'un des groupes de la nupes vous
leur laissez régler leurs problèmes de
famille entre eux je les laisse régler
mais il me paraît donc une candidate
dont l'élection est saluée comme ça a
été le cas et je le disais tout à
l'heure de Monsieur dussoft à Monsieur
Odoul n'a pas sa place dans un des
groupes de la nupes pour les soutiens de
Martin frog c'est une victoire je cite
de la gauche républicaine face à une
gauche dominée par la France insoumise
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez je suis
pas sûr que Monsieur Julien Oudot le
soit de la gauche républicaine et le
porte-parole du rassemblement national
Bernard Cazeneuve défendent cette goutte
républicaine mais il y a tout ça n'a pas
de sens et la nupesse est bien
évidemment républicaine donc tout ça n'a
pas de sens la réalité de ce qui s'est
produit en arrière et qu'on aurait tort
de vouloir généraliser d'ailleurs c'est
que la candidate dissidente a été le
réceptacle de tous les battus du premier
tour de la candidate macroniste du
premier tour qui je le rappelle quand
même a fait 10% des voix c'est un
enseignement qui est très important d'un
point de vue national jusqu'au candidat
du Rassemblement national qui a été
éliminé au premier tour et la candidate
dissidente a servi de réceptable de
réceptacles pardon à l'ensemble de ses
battus du du premier tour si Madame
Delga ou monsieur Cazeneuve considère
que c'est un enseignement pour la suite
d'être élu au deuxième tour face à la
nups avec le soutien de la droite et de
l'extrême droite je les laisse à ces
approximations où je les laisse assez
considérations est-ce que cette défaite
en législative partielle c'est pas aussi
un échec de la stratégie de la France
insoumise dans cette mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites une stratégie
avec du bruit de l'obstruction parfois
même de l'eau transverbal non mais bon
si vous voulez mais vous pouvez vous
pouvez retenir si vous le souhaitez
juste ce qui s'est passé hier dans une
circonscription particulière à l'Ariège
mais moi je peux vous parler de
l'élection législative partielle qui a
eu lieu en Charente au mois de janvier
où nous avons gagné un député de plus
René Pilato alors qu'il avait perdu au
mois de juin je peux vous parler
d'autres élections législatives
partielles qui ont eu lieu hier soir
chez les Français de l'étranger par
exemple du candidat Karim benchek qui a
fait 42% des voix au premier tour donc
voilà il faut pas tirer des
enseignements d'une situation
particulière avec un second tour tout à
fait particulier parce qu'encore une
fois il est l'opposé une candidat de la
nupes et une candidature dissidente mais
en tout cas est-ce que vous êtes à
revoir la stratégie
veulent tout remettre à plat même
Jean-Luc Mélenchon hier disait qu'il
était prêt à un acte 2 de la nups non
mais c'est pas tout remettre à plat mais
c'est de se poser la question de comment
on prolonge comment on approfondi encore
cette stratégie de la nupette qui est
encore une fois à démontrer ses
résultats il y aurait pas eu 151 députés
à l'Assemblée nationale de la nups il y
avait pas eu cet accord donc la question
ensuite c'est comment on avance comment
on franchit une nouvelle étape dans cet
accord et ça moi j'y suis favorable mais
je suis pas favorable depuis aujourd'hui
il y a un mois de ça j'ai envoyé un
courrier au socialiste aux écologistes
au communistes en faisant un certain
nombre de propositions pour faire en
sorte que la nupaisse franchisse une
nouvelle étape donc oui il faut le faire
et il faut qu'on en discute le plus
rapidement possible manuel Bompard on va
parler du maintien de l'ordre et des
violences qu'on connaît actuellement
autour de certaines manifestations
Gérald de Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur hier dans le Journal du
Dimanche estime que l'extrême gauche et
notamment la France insoumise fait je
cite du terrorisme intellectuel en
critiquant la police plutôt que les
casseurs que lui répondez vous d'abord
dans votre question la France insoumise
n'est pas d'extrême gauche il faut
arrêter avec ce cirque l'extrême gauche
ça existe en France il y a des parties
qui se revendiquent de l'extrême gauche
il faut les respecter mais la France
insoumise n'est pas d'extrême gauche ça
c'est la première chose que que je vais
je sais pas c'est pas ma gauche mais le
programme politique que l'on porte n'est
pas un programme politique d'extrême
gauche qui a une définition et des
parties qui se revendiquent de l'extrême
gauche bon ça c'est la première chose à
dire la deuxième chose à dire c'est que
manifestement monsieur Darmanin est en
campagne monsieur Darmanin veut
remplacer madame born à Matignon tout le
monde l'a compris et donc pour essayer
de se singulariser
il va dans les outrances qui sont tout à
fait insupportables parce que vous savez
le terrorisme je crois que tout le monde
sait à quoi ça correspond le terrorisme
c'est malheureusement des gens qui
meurent derrière donc faut pas raconter
n'importe quoi et le fait d'être en
campagne pour essayer d'être Premier
ministre Premier ministre à la place de
Madame borne justifie pas toutes les
outrances la France insoumise elle
défend dans cette bataille puisque c'est
de ça dont on parle sur les retraites
elle défend et elle porte la parole des
70% des Français qui sont opposés à
cette réforme et Monsieur Darmanin
plutôt diabolisé son opposition de
réessayer d'entendre la parole qui
s'exprime dans la rue depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois et de lui donner une
réponse plutôt que de l'ignorer ou de
vouloir passer en force comme il le fait
on a l'impression qu'il est devenu un
peu votre meilleur ami non c'est pas un
bon ennemi non moi je d'abord je pense
que il fait beaucoup de mal et Monsieur
Darmanin parce que en
diabolisant comme ça d'abord il
dédiabolise l'extrême droite
alors que je vous rappelle comme c'est
le même monsieur Darmanin qui disait sur
un plateau de télévision à Madame Le Pen
qu'elle était trop molle c'est ça
monsieur Darmanin ce qui fait donc non
je pense que Monsieur Darmanin fait
beaucoup de mal à la République à la
démocratie en tenant ce type de propos
en tout cas il a annoncé hier la
création d'une cellule anti-zades au
ministère de l'intérieur avec des
juristes spécialisés le problème il
promet qu'il n'y aura plus de ZAD en
France c'est plutôt en bon objectif mais
bon ça c'est des mots c'est c'est des
phrases c'est des verbes avant on avait
le droit de faire des aides en France
enfin qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire la question qui est posée quand
il y a des gens qui décident d'aller sur
un lieu pour s'y installer pour dénoncer
on peut essayer de s'attaquer à eux si
vous voulez mais la question qui est
posée c'est de savoir pourquoi il le
font quand des gens vont manifester
contre les bassines comme c'est le cas
comme ça a été le cas la semaine
dernière on peut si on veut
effectivement retenir quelques personnes
qui sont venues avec des intentions
violentes mais on peut aussi essayer de
se poser la question de savoir pourquoi
il y avait des milliers de personnes qui
sont venues manifester pacifiquement
parce qu'ils sont inquiets sur la
manière avec laquelle on va faire face
dans les années et les décennies qui
viennent à la pénurie d'eau et aux
problèmes de l'eau bon donc c'est assez
question c'est aux questions de fond
qu'il faut répondre faut arrêter en
permanence d'essayer de diaboliser de de
de créer des affrontements non il faut
répondre aux questions de fonds qui sont
posées et la question de l'eau c'est une
question centrale et ça fait des années
et des années que nous le disons je
rappelle que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
commencé sa campagne présidentielle sur
la question de l'eau donc vaut mieux
attaquer au fond des choses plutôt que
d'essayer de s'en prendre comme ça aux
gens qui manifestent mais ce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne diabolise pas dans
notre côté la police en critiquant
l'accent des policiers pendant ces
manifestations actuellement mais pas du
tout enfin écoutez depuis quand dans ce
pays on peut pas dire que des policiers
qui ne respectent pas la déontologie
doivent être remis en place et doivent
être critiqués enfin qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette histoire c'est à dire que
maintenant si on dénonce un certain
nombre d'actes qui sont commis un
dispositif de maintien de l'ordre qui
est tout à fait excessif et tout à fait
qui ne fonctionne pas enfin excusez-moi
mais la responsabilité du ministère de
l'intérieur c'est quoi c'est à la fois
de permettre qu'il y a un certain nombre
de liberté constitutionnelles qui soient
garantie la liberté de manifester et en
même temps de protéger les personnes qui
travaillent sous sa responsabilité en
l'occurrence dans le 400 sollines les
gendarmes bon dans ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière aucun de ces deux
objectifs n'a été remplis bon donc il y
a une doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
qu'on a le droit de critiquer qu'on a le
droit de remettre en cause et tout ça et
documenter vous avez vu des images bon
donc on a quand même le droit de dire ça
sans être immédiatement catalygué
catalogué pardon comme anti-pollution ou
en tifly qui a pas dentifric à la France
insoumise mais quand les policiers font
mal leur travail on a le droit de le
dire et puis quand ils font bien leur
travail on le dit aussi trois morts
cette nuit à Marseille
14 ans je crois depuis le début de
l'année sur la ville euh c'est la
politique Gérald Darmanin qui est en
cause bah en tout cas manifestement
monsieur Darmanin il est fort pour faire
des moulinets de parole pour venir faire
le gros bras sur les plateaux de
télévision mais pas pour garantir la
sécurité des Françaises et des Français
et ce qui se passe à Marseille comme
dans d'autres villes c'est que on a des
règlements de compte on a des trafics
qui gangrènent et qui pourrissent la vie
d'un certain nombre de de de Françaises
et de français et donc la question qui
nous est posée c'est comment on
s'attaque sérieusement à ce problème et
de mon point de vue par exemple on
s'attaque sérieusement à ce problème en
mettant des moyens dans la police
judiciaire en développant les moyens
d'enquête ça n'a pas été fait ça n'a pas
été fait je je pense que suffisamment je
pense pense que Monsieur Darmanin veut
parce que il est dans une stratégie
médiatique donc il veut une politique du
chiffre donc il veut pouvoir dire on a
mis des des amendes à des consommateurs
de drogue et au moins on voyait on agit
mais ça ne répond pas ça ne résout pas
le problème si vous voulez résoudre le
problème vous devez aller chercher à
infiltrer à pénétrer à démanteler les
réseaux les réseaux de trafic de drogue
les réseaux de trafic d'armes parce
qu'après ça a des conséquences très
concrètes sur la vie des gens donc oui
je pense que là aussi on a un désaccord
qui est un désaccord radical avec
Monsieur Darmanin les questions de
sécurité elles mérite mieux que de venir
faire les gros bras sur les plateaux de
télévision elle mérite des résultats qui
sont des résultats concrets et
malheureusement ils sont pas là manuel
Bompard on va parler de la réforme des
retraites et de la préparation pour le
gouvernement de la suite du quinquennat
Elisabeth borne la première ministre
consulte mercredi l'Inter sadical est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est la discussion
peuvent aboutir à quelque chose
on va voir
la terre syndicale ça fait depuis
plusieurs semaines qui demandent à être
reçu initialement madame borne leur a
dit je veux bien vous recevoir mais on
parlera de tous sauf des retraites ce
qui est quand même lunaire c'est le
sujet qui occupe le pays depuis deux
mois il semble maintenant qu'elle
accepte l'idée qu'on puisse au moins en
parler moi je lui dis juste une chose
c'est que si à la fin de ce rendez-vous
c'est un aboutit pas sur une décision
claire qui est le retrait de ce texte de
loi ou la décision du Président de la
République donne pas le promulguer ça ne
résoudra en rien la colère qui s'exprime
dans ce pays et qui est toujours aussi
forte est-ce que ça voudra dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron a gagné le bras de
fer de quoi si c'est un aboutira rien
non monsieur Macron a déjà perdu sur la
bataille des retraites et là déjà perdu
parce que après deux mois et d'ailleurs
vous remarquez que il n'a plus un seul
argument sur le fond pour essayer de
justifier le bien-fondé de sa réforme on
ne parle plus du fond de cette réforme
pourquoi parce qu'il a compris que
personne n'était convaincu que vous avez
70% des Français qui sont contre plus de
90% des actifs et que ce texte n'a même
pas de légitimité parlementaire donc
s'il passe en force par le long terme
oui le parlementaire
l'Assemblée nationale le texte est
valable mais je ne la Constitution lui
donne des outils pour passer en force je
ne le conteste pas mais c'est pour ça
c'est pas pour ça que je considère que
c'est légitime bon donc monsieur Macron
2 ce point de vue là a déjà perdu
maintenant l'objectif c'est de gagner
complètement et gagner complètement
c'est obtenir le retrait de cette
réforme et vous le savez il y a des
nouvelles étapes dans la rue il y a une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation jeudi
moi je souhaite qu'elle soit la plus
puissante possible et je dis aux gens si
on est nombreux si on défile par
millions jeudi on peut obtenir le
retrait de cette réforme et puis je dis
aussi aux gens il faut aller aider ceux
qui sont dans la grève parce que il y a
un certain nombre de secteurs qui sont
rentrés dans des mouvements de grève
c'est difficile c'est vrai ça coûte de
l'argent c'est pas facile de faire la
grève mais il y en a qui porte le
mouvement de grève depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines et bah il faut les
aider donc il faut généraliser la grève
jeudi en tout cas c'est ce que je pense
et si l'Inter syndical reprenait ce mot
d'ordre par exemple de essayer de
généraliser la grève jeudi je pense que
ce serait une bonne chose pour la lutte
et puis mardi les parlementaires
insoumis et communistes vont marcher
vers l'Elysée l'objectif c'est de
remettre une lettre au président de la
République et puis aussi de protester
contre cette réforme c'est une bonne
démarche cette marche vers l'Elysée il y
a pas un petit symbole révolutionnaire
non mais ça a été proposé d'abord je
veux le dire par les députés communistes
qui ont souhaité prendre cette
initiative nous aussi joint avec avec
plaisir et l'objectif c'est d'aller
interpeller celui qui décide vraiment
honnêtement tout le monde sait que c'est
pas Madame borne qui décide vraiment sur
cette réforme des retraites c'est
Monsieur Macron donc c'est à lui qu'il
faut parler donc on va aller le voir on
va lui demander effectivement maintenant
écoutez la parole des Françaises et des
Français et retirer cette réforme
reculée il y a pas de honte à reculer et
parfois c'est mieux de reculer quand on
n'est pas en capacité de faire passer
cette réforme dans des bonnes conditions
je rappelle que Monsieur Chirac avait
reculé sur le contrat premier embauche
que Monsieur Juppé avait reculé en 1995
sous la sous la présidence de Monsieur
Chirac aussi il y a pas à reculer ils en
sont pas morts est-ce que vous appelez
les Français à participer aussi à cette
marche vers l'Elysée non mais je crois
que c'est une initiative qui a une
initiative parlementaire après les gens
font ce qu'ils veulent moi je peux pas
j'ai pas le pouvoir de leur dire venez
pas mais l'initiative qui a été proposée
par les députés communistes et une
initiative de parlementaire qui vont
devant l'Élysée maintenant si des gens
viennent ils viennent et voilà c'est
comme ça voilà vous le met pas aussi le
ce que les Français aussi ils
participent pourquoi les députés
insoumis refusent les entretiens que
Elisabeth borne la première ministre va
commencer cette semaine avec les partis
politiques pour préparer la suite du
quinquennat précisément pour la raison
qui est dans votre question c'est que
l'objectif de ces entretiens et ça a été
dit d'ailleurs par Monsieur Macron quand
il a confié à Madame borne c'est
d'essayer de trouver une nouvelle
majorité d'élargir la majorité pour la
suite du quinquennat en essayant de
faire comme si la bataille sur les
retraites était close mais elle est pas
close l'opposition elle est toujours
aussi forte donc le sujet c'est pas de
préparer la suite le sujet c'est comment
on sort du moment dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui bon premièrement et
deuxièmement monsieur Riester a dit que
toute façon il fallait venir parler avec
Madame borgne uniquement des sujets sur
lesquels on est d'accord donc moi j'ai
pas l'intention d'aller parler avec
Madame borne des sujets sur lesquels je
suis d'accord parce que je suis pas
d'accord notamment sur cette réforme des
retraites donc tout ça est une stratégie
de communication ces entretiens et
l'ensemble des groupes de la nuit pêche
j'espère que vous l'avez remarqué ni
participerons pas est-ce que vous croyez
encore au RIP
sur la réforme des retraites en tout cas
nous on a déposé on a donné nos
signatures pour que ce cette proposition
puisse être examinée par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc pourquoi pas mais
aujourd'hui ça c'est un quelque chose de
moyen ou de long terme aujourd'hui la
bataille c'est une bataille de court
terme la bataille de court terme c'est
pour obtenir le retrait de ce texte de
loi et pour obtenir le retrait de ce
texte de loi ça passera pas par le RIB
ça passera par l'extension encore de la
mobilisation dans la rue ce jeudi dans
toutes les initiatives qui vont être
prises d'ailleurs d'ici là et par
l'extension de la grève c'est simple si
on veut gagner c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire donc moi je veux pas que les gens
croient qu'ils puissent y avoir une
autre possibilité pour gagner que celle
de ce mobiliser c'est très simple si
vous vous mobilisez pas à la fin
monsieur Macron il passera en force
voilà donc chacun a une part de la de la
de la responsabilité de cette bataille
entre ses mains il faut se mettre en
action il faut se mettre en mouvement
manuel bon parc quelques questions sur
la fin de vie puisque la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie remet ses
travaux aujourd'hui au président de la
République une convention citoyenne qui
s'est en faveur de l'euthanasie et du
suicide assisté vous attendez une loi
sur ce sujet je pense que c'est
nécessaire effectivement d'ailleurs les
députés de la France insoumise dans leur
niche parlementaire je crois que c'était
en 2019 en 2020 avait déposé une
proposition de loi sur ce sujet à
l'époque et on n'était pas les seuls
d'autres initiatives ont été prises à
l'Assemblée nationale vous savez c'est
un sujet qui a un sujet par essence et
par définition assez transpartisans il y
a des gens dans toutes les familles
politiques qui défendent cette cette
revendication donc maintenant je pense
que le débat a suffisamment évolué dans
notre pays pour que on puisse introduire
cette disposition dans la loi bon nous
on pensait même qu'on pouvait
l'introduire dans la Constitution on
peut le faire par référendum si on pense
que c'est ce qui permet peut-être de
donner j'ai envie de dire une assise
populaire la plus large possible à cette
propulsion référendum sur la fin de vie
c'est toujours un sujet qui est complexe
mais comment on sait que c'est un sujet
qui renvoie parfois à des choses
philosophiques à des choses qui sont
très intimes je pense que pour que la
décision ne soit pas contestée de ce
point de vue là un référendum pourrait
permettre que tout le monde se dise bon
voilà les Français ont choisi on
tranchait donc maintenant c'est ça la
loi sur sur la méthode la convention
citoyenne c'était déjà un bon point
souhaité par Emmanuel Macron je le
précise mais bon si vous voulez que je
dise du bien d'Emmanuel Macron c'est ça
les conventions citoyennes c'est une
bonne chose si à la fin ce qui est
décidé par les conventions citoyennes
devient effectivement une réalité donc
si à la fin ça permet d'aboutir sur une
proposition de loi sur la fin de vie et
le suicide assisté très bien mais je
rappelle que la dernière fois il y a eu
une autre convention citoyenne sur le
climat et que les les 90% des mesures
qui avaient été préconisées par cette
convention citoyenne n'ont pas été
suivies d'effet donc moi je suis
toujours favorable à des dispositifs qui
permettent de faire de la politique
différemment et de permettre aux
citoyens d'avoir des pouvoirs de
décision mais à la fin faut pas enterrer
ce qu'il préconise parce que ça convient
pas au président de la République donc
pour répondre à votre question je vais
dire on en reparle dans un an et on
verra si ça aboutit effectivement sur un
changement de la loi alors il y a une
autre loi importante qui va être
présentée demain en Conseil des
ministres c'est la loi de programmation
militaire 413 milliards d'euros vont
être investi pour nos armées d'ici à
2030 c'est nécessaire ou c'est un peu
excessif ce montant d'abord ça démontre
que contrairement à ce qu'on dit sur
l'autre sujet dont on parlait tout à
l'heure sur les retraites quand on veut
aller chercher des ressources
financières on est en capacité de le
faire donc les arguments qui
consistaient à dire on n'a pas d'autres
choix que de reculer l'âge de départ à
la retraite parce que sinon c'est la
faillite la ruine monsieur du soft avait
dit ça à l'Assemblée nationale tout le
monde doit se rendre compte à ce
moment-là que c'est ces arguments sont
des arguments complètement loufoques
pour le reste nos armées notre capacité
de défense elle doit avoir des moyens
financiers pour qu'on soit en capacité
de se défendre tout simplement donc moi
sur le principe j'ai pas d'objection sur
le sujet c'était un engagement qu'on
avait pris aussi de faire en sorte que
nos armées soient suffisamment équipées
pour pouvoir nous défendre dans des
bonnes conditions donc les députés
insoumis voteront cette fois-ci
on verra pour l'instant ce que vous
m'avez posé une question sur le niveau
de moyens alloué ensuite il y a des
débats à l'intérieur
quel est son nos priorités il y a quelle
est notre doctrine générale il y a
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en matière de
spatial qu'est-ce qu'on fait en matière
de cybersécurité bon vous voyez il y a
tous ces sujets là et on va en débattre
moi ce que j'observe c'est que à nouveau
vous avez un ministre qui vient faire un
certain nombre de déclaration dans la
presse alors que sur ce type de sujet si
on pouvait avoir d'abord un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que ce
serait pas mal 10 milliards d'euros pour
le nouveau porte-avion qui va remplacer
le Charles de Gaulle là aussi c'est
nécessaire précisément voilà vous donner
un exemple de sujet sur lequel ce serait
bien qu'on puisse en débattre moi je dis
pas non par principe mais ça dépend
comment ça s'articule avec le reste de
la doctrine de de défense de notre de
notre pays donc je voudrais pas que le
porte-avion soit un petit peu l'arbre
qui cache la forêt d'un débat nécessaire
sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait de notre
politique de défense dans les années qui
viennent dernière question sur l'Ukraine
manuel Bompard l'Assemblée nationale a
reconnu la semaine dernière le génocide
ukrainien de Lolo de mort dans les
années 1930 c'est une grande famine
orchestrée par Staline qui a tué plus
d'un million de personnes les députés
insoumis n'ont pas pris par au vote
pourquoi bah d'abord bien évidemment le
lot de marre et quelque chose d'ignoble
ça c'est une évidence maintenant la
caractérisation de génocide elle
correspond selon l'ONU à un certain
nombre de critères qui de notre point de
vue dans ce cas de figure là ne sont pas
réunis et je crois qu'il faut faire
toujours attention quand l'Assemblée
nationale veut commencer à écrire
l'histoire c'est aux historiens de de le
faire il y a trois génocides qui sont
reconnus aujourd'hui à l'échelle
internationale il y a un certain nombre
de critères qui correspondent il me
semble que le cas de l'automne n'y
correspond pas c'est pour ça qu'on a pas
participé au vote en même temps on n'a
pas voté compte parce que il est évident
que ce qui s'est passé en Ukraine à
cette époque là et tout à fait
insupportable merci beaucoup Emmanuel
Bompard d'avoir été notre invité
politique aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
Fabrice
de la France tout de suite le club des
territoires